weapons
surviving in the shadows the citizens
finding safety in underground trains as
ukraine's president accuses moscow of
kidnapping children
there are russian troops who are killing
and raping people and kidnapping
children torturing people and looting
one of the kremlin's most vocal critics
opposition leader alexei navalny is
sentenced to nine more years in a
maximum security prison
the super arch reportedly belonging to
the billionaire roman abramovich blocked
by protesters in turkey
[Music]
hello good afternoon officials in the
besieged city of marriott have defiantly
rejected russian demands to lay down
arms and surrender in exchange for safe
passage moscow has intensified its
efforts to bombard the strategic port
city but elsewhere western governments
say russia's offensive has floundered
all this lunchtime ukraine's foreign
ministry is warning that more than 2 000
children have been in their words
kidnapped from the regions of luhansk
and donetsk
the u.s president joe biden has again
said that moscow could be considering
using chemical weapons
a curfew is still in place in the
capital kiev until 7 am local time
tomorrow
and the un's refugee agency says a total
of 3.5 million people have now fled
ukraine
sky's charlotte lomas has this report
one after another the bombs fall this
time the target is an industrial centre
in maripo
factories that once provided jobs
destroyed in an instant
marropol has been under constant fire
for weeks
homes across the city reduced to ruin
officials say around 90 percent of
buildings have been damaged here
the incessant fighting has forced these
ukrainian families to flee but with
nowhere to go they line their cars along
one of the city's roads
the russian word for children clearly
marked on windows hoping this might keep
them safe
but in this besieged city it seems
anything goes
russians have attacked hospitals schools
a theater
these satellite pictures show the vast
extent of destruction
time is running out for people trapped
inside this city as food water and
medicine are scarce
three hundred thousand people in
mariupol uh without food
it's not the war anymore
and in the siege city we clearly see
that russia wants to start hunger just
to enforce its diplomatic position on
the diplomatic processes
and what's that russia does
[Music]
and there could be a further threat
chechnyan soldiers have released this
video claiming they are in mariopol and
have joined the fight
the location or date of this footage
couldn't be verified but the chechens
want to show they're standing strong
with russia
ukraine's leader remains defiant but is
yet again calling for help from europe
speaking to the italian parliament this
time zlensky warned the russian advance
won't stop at ukraine
we are now on the brink of survival
ukraine for russian troops is the
gateway into europe where they want to
break in but this barbarism must be
stopped you know who brought this war to
ukraine those who are supporting this
war all of them are using italy as a
place for holidays so please don't be a
holiday resort to murderers
in turkey it definitely hasn't been a
warm welcome for associates of putin
protesters here boarding a motorboat and
trying to block roman abramovich's super
yacht from docking in bodrum
there's no stopping the thousands of
ordinary ukrainians crossing the border
into europe though every day more people
come with only their most precious
belongings
not knowing what's in store
just thankful they've escaped charlotte
lomas sky news
this guy's mate martin joins us live
from the port city of odessa and nick
what is
the latest where you are
well yesterday we saw some shelling the
first shelling
coming from russian warships that have
been out in the black sea for a few
weeks now about six shells came in
land hitting an apartment block and
several other buildings the
ukrainian military responded by saying
that it was
trying to terrorize the population of
odessa but also
trying to figure out the weaknesses in
the odessan defense
system which apparently is pretty good
here um
there had been some rockets fired in
over the last week but we're told that
they had been
intercepted so in odessa
it's a sort of
normal scene really people going about
their business whilst at the same time
the city is pretty well defended it is a
different story of course further east
from here in mikhail
and of course mario paul those other
port cities that are under pretty
sustained attack now the uk defense
intelligence service says that although
there is heavy fighting in mario pole
the russian advance is being held back
and that is perhaps one of the reasons
why we haven't seen an offensive on
odessa yet the sort of pl pieces that
would have to come into play for that to
happen we're told would be more of an
advance from the north through cave and
more in advance through mario paul and
mikalia from the east before the perhaps
the russian navy on the coast here might
feel confident an assault on odessa
which is a a key target in any event
would begin to
happen
we've heard from the president of
ukraine vladimir zelinski today who's
made some very serious claims about how
the russians are treating adults and
children he is claiming that uh that
thousands of children have been abducted
in as part of this war this is what he
had to say today
there are russian troops who are killing
and raping people and kidnapping
children torturing people and looting
they take our property back to russia on
trucks this is what nazis did during the
war when they occupied other countries
now the u.s embassy in kiev has uh
backed up these comments by vladimir
zolensky they said according to
ukrainian foreign ministry russian
forces have illegally removed 2
389 ukrainian children from donetsk and
luhansk that's in the east all blasts
the regions
to russia they said this is not
assistance it is kidnapping of course
both sides have things to say in this
war this this is what happens in
conflict
but if these reports are correct then
that that would be a very serious
humanitarian uh situation but here in
odessa you know they there's a feeling
of something is gonna happen but we
think that the the the russian advance
isn't going as fast as they thought and
so they don't feel absolutely confident
about mounting an assault on odessa and
what we saw yesterday in those shells
coming down may have just been a warning
shot to test the defenses of this key
port city
nick thanks very much thanks for the
latest from odessa
well of course for many in ukraine life
is getting a lot harder in kharkiv
families are living in underground rail
carriages to avoid russian shelling it
is ukraine's second city around 25 miles
from the border with russia our
correspondent john sparks has this
report which does contain images of
injured people
the streets of harkiev have been
abandoned by the majority of those who
live here
half a million have fled this city
their prized possessions in a bag
and their cars discarded at the station
those who remain hide in the shadows in
the dark or the deep underground
more than a dozen metro stations have
been turned into shelters
these battered looking train carriages
redeployed as home how long have you
been living here uh three or three three
weeks how do you feel about it so first
yeah when we hear something blow up
we're around here but now we're like
what was that oh shooting
the experience is a trial for a new
mother called natalya
she gave birth to her son two days after
the invasion began
the hospital
[Music]
yeah
they now live in the final car on
platform 2 with a cot and clothes
provided by volunteers
natalia says life will never be the same
against
when a russian missile struck this
institute the entire neighborhood was
damaged in the blast
eighty-five-year-old stella
told us she hung on to the door frame in
the hope she'd survive what was it like
when
the bombing happened when the missile
hit
yeah
[Music]
one of her neighbors called deanna was
not so fortunate
she was caught in the explosion glass
from the windows puncturing her face
her doctor at harkeev's main hospital
said there's a fine line between life
and death
next door we found four men fighting for
their lives
one hit by shrapnel another blown up by
a mine
sergey is an opera singer turned
volunteer who was shot seven times as he
tried to evacuate local residents
and he celebrated with an old italian
song of resistance
[Music]
death and displacement have come to
everybody's doorstep but there are many
here who are determined to hold on
john sparks sky news harkev
well let's get the latest analysis on
the situation on the ground in ukraine
wilfred frost is here
thanks so much uh i'm joined by retired
vice marshal sean bell advisor for
universal defence and security solutions
sean great to see you again
we're trying something a little
different today looking at the expansion
of nato over the last three decades
ahead of course of president biden's
trip to poland this weekend sort of to
try and get in the mindset of how the
russians might look at this or
realistically the spin
president putin might apply to it and
sean starting here in the mid 1990s a
few years after the fall of the soviet
union the original 12 members of nato
from 1949 and four others had joined by
then yeah still it was formed as an
essentially um defensive alliance an
attack on any one would be attack on on
everyone and of course defense of your
people your nation is the number one
priority for any nation i think the very
success of the alliance had mentioned it
had grown slightly but even at this
stage you can see quite a considerable
buffer between the eastern edge of nato
and russia
and now if we jump to today we'll see
essentially that buffer uh disappear
only really uh belarus and ukraine of
the the big nations that remain as a
buffer in russian eyes yeah and i think
you've also got to overlay on this that
in the late 90s putin effectively came
to power he's been in power for 23 years
now
and so he's presided over sort of the
dissolution of the soviet uh former
soviet union and of course when the
collapse of the soviet union we saw
several new states emerge particularly
on the back of a stagnant economy and
those states wanted to find wealth
prosperity and freedom some of them
looked east and have formed alliances
with russia but some of them looked west
particularly the baltic states and part
of the warsaw pact to and saw wealth and
prosperity through the european union
and through nato which is where they
expanded and of course uh worth
reiterating it was a defensive
organization and all the countries that
did join sought to join as opposed to to
outright expansion if you will
from existing nato members sean just
talk us through exactly what is going on
on the ground in some of the eastern
flank nations of nato in terms of
operations defensive uh moves and the
like well of course nato doesn't wait
until somebody attacks one of its member
nations it has to respond to a threat so
putin's advance into the ukraine has
heightened tensions so nato is
bolstering all of its eastern flank with
nato and that's why we're seeing some
deployment of nato aircraft faster
aircraft into the baltic states we're
seeing ground troop deployments into
some of the central region and we're
seeing um bolstering of ground radar
systems surface-to-air missile systems
etc to provide a really robust deterrent
for any further putin expansionism the
irony here of course is that if putin
had actually wanted to arrest the
expansion of nato he shouldn't have
invaded a free country like ukraine oh
absolutely and let's dive into the
situation on the ground in in ukraine
the latest this map we've been looking
at a lot over the last couple of days of
course awful tragedies continue and
shelling of cities like mario paul
if there's a small positive though uh
sean is it that we haven't seen much
expansion of what's shaded red here has
the russian advance stalled it's very
difficult the world stall implies a
sense of hope i think um certainly the
ukrainian resistance both military and
civilian around mario poll has
undoubtedly caused putin to pause and
undoubtedly if he's having that
difficulty in mariopol he'll have a much
more difficult time up in kiev i think
part of this is also a huge testament to
the bravery and the tenacity of the
ukrainian forces and we're even seeing
um signs now that they're fighting back
their season initiative seizing
background that russia had taken which
is causing all sorts of problems for
russian resupply sure thanks so much for
that that's the latest here on day 27.
thanks very much will
now one of president putin's most
high-profile critics has been given a
further jail sentence today alexei
navalny was found guilty of fraud and
contempt of court and jailed for nine
years he was already serving a two and a
half year sentence for parole violations
at a prison just outside of moscow
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest edition of the sky news daily
podcast today nikkoreshi speaks to our
security and defense editor debra haynes
and the russian security expert aglaia
snetkov about how the war in ukraine
could end and the red lines in
negotiations you can subscribe to the
daily wherever you get your podcasts
from
and reminded tonight we'll have a
special question and answer session on
the war in ukraine for defense and
security analyst michael clark that's at
seven o'clock here on sky news
this is sky news today coming up we'll
have a report from the small town of
utica north of kiev it's the last
community before the front line of
russian held territory
[Music]
the surge in prices is squeezing all our
finances with rising fuel costs
inflation and higher food bills the cost
of living is going up and up
how will the chancellor's spring
statement help reduce the cost of living
crisis
the spring statement on sky news
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ukraine's capital kiev has faced a daily
barrage of air and artillery attacks sky
special correspondent alex crawford
traveled to the small town of lutisch
north of kiev it is the last community
before the front line of russian-held
territory from there she sent this
report
the capitals northern suburbs are under
attack the skyline's increasingly
clouded after rocket strikes
the russian military is trying to push
closer into the city but they've got to
get through three small communities in
between
we're rushed through checkpoints the
shells land here without warning causing
fires which rip through this forested
area
and in lutus they know they're the ones
now holding the line against the
russians so they're digging trenches
and bolstering their positions
the communities already been hit several
times
the attacks have left yet more people
without homes
and workplaces and businesses have been
left shattered
but the main supermarket is still
operating despite being shelled earlier
the staff are just wiping down their
supplies and carrying on regardless
we even know how to protect ourselves if
something is incoming she says we lie
down and cover our heads
a lot of the fridges and storage areas
are damaged the constant volley of
attacks has seen half the town empty the
other half can't understand why this is
happening
they've attacked our houses our schools
our shops she said they're hurting us
too much for what please someone explain
nadia shows us the crater that's been
left in her back garden parts of the
rocket still visible
god loves me she says i can't believe
i'm alive
inside her house she shows us how almost
every room is affected with the ceiling
down and windows shattered
she lives alone with her 81 year old
mother who's clearly unsettled
granny was born during the second world
war nadia explains about her mother now
she has to survive another
her mother and her have been here all
their lives leaving is inconceivable
and for those who've lived through this
all before the war has awful echoes
her daughter interrupts children are
dying women are dying she says this
isn't just war this is destroying this
is genocide of the people they're just
killing us to eliminate us they want to
remove us from the surface of the land
so they see their defense of these
northern suburbs as critical
and the sounds of russians nearby seems
constant once we're here
they're nazis he says
and there's another attack
he waits to hear if it's landing close
by
he was a swimming coach a few weeks ago
now everyone here is a bombing
the man taking us into their bunker was
a tv producer now part of the army
keeping the foreign troops outside the
capital how will they be able to get
inside keith do you think
[Music]
no they cannot capture keep he says they
can try to surround it but if they try
to enter they'll face very heavy
resistance
and helping them is leon from chichester
who came to kiev on his motorbike and
went straight to the front line i
thought to myself
how could i not do something about this
how can i not go out there and help
especially seeing the war crimes being
committed on civilian populations i just
thought that i can't can't sit by and
let this happen
he's standing shoulder to shoulder with
the ukrainian volunteers helping out as
a medic and now defending kiev
they've got mannequins at the entrance
of lutish to try to confuse any russian
snipers the residents inside here know
this could be a long drawn-out and
bloody war
alex crawford sky news in the northern
outskirts of kiev
let's get a look at the weather
the next few days mostly fine with long
clear spells bringing warm days and
chilly nights it'll be warmer than
yesterday for most this afternoon with a
high of 20 celsius 68 fahrenheit
possible
somewhere in the south
an onshore breeze will keep it cooler
near some coasts mainly in the northeast
and the southwest
it'll be largely dry with good sunny
spells but a few heavy showers are also
possible the midlands and ireland look
most at risk but the old one can't be
ruled out over northern england and
southern scotland too
those showers will soon fade to leave a
dry and clear night with a patchy frost
developing in the countryside
some fog too mostly for the northeast of
england tomorrow looks dry for most with
plenty of sunshine once that early fog
burns back to the coast but eastern
parts may catch the odd shower it'll
turn out warm again but some coastal
areas will be rather cool
especially in the south thursday will be
similar but not quite as warm
springer sprung
you're watching sky news coming up what
effect will the war in ukraine have on
the chancellor's spring statement we'll
discuss that next
[Music]
so
[Music]
the war in ukraine is expected to have a
huge impact on the chancellor's spring
statement tomorrow the impact of
sanctions and rising prices are going to
of course have a significant impact on
the treasury joining me now deputy
chairman of the center for economics and
business research douglas mcwilliams um
good to talk to you today mr mick
williams um
what impact do you think that the war is
currently having on our personal finance
against advances or personal finances i
mean obviously we're seeing fuel prices
for one go up but what else well it
pushed up the price of fuel it pushes up
the price of heating oil it pushes up
the price of gas it pushes up the price
of metals
it pushes up the price of food
and of course there's not just an
immediate effect as we're seeing with
the fuel pumps but there will be effects
that work their way through over the
next five or six months
as the cost of higher transport and so
on feeds themselves feeds their way
through into everything that we buy
and as ever it is the poorest in society
who disproportionately will pay more for
this won't it
it's not always the case that the
poorest pay more but in this particular
case it is this is because the poor pay
roughly twice as much for their energy
they also if they drive they spend
proportionately twice as much on fuel
and of course the poor spend a much
higher proportion of their income on
food as well so these three things that
are particularly hit by this are things
that really do hit the pool so the
chance is going to have to do something
tomorrow to try and alleviate that
problem
so what are his options what could he do
they're all to do with tax he could
reverse some of the decisions he's made
already raising the national insurance
contribution
which comes in in april um he could
unfreeze the personal allowances but i
think he probably has to start
with the things that affect the poorest
people and of course the most direct way
of putting money into the poorest
people's hands is to raise universal
credits i think he really has to do that
first before he does anything else
do you think it's likely that he will
i think it's fairly likely he's going to
have to do something to help the poorest
people then there are a series of other
options he can reduce the duty on fuel
prices he can have a temporary reduction
in vat
he can
subsidize the energy cap there are some
difficulties though with subsidizing
things like energy usage i know you
probably will have to do some of it but
of course um
one of the signals that we're getting
from this is we ought to be reducing our
dependence on high cost energy and
unless you let the cost go through to
some extent unless you allow a bit of
the pain
to emerge
it's hard to send the signal to people
that they ought to be reducing their
usage
that's interesting they sort of almost
need to feel the pinch themselves
and moderate their behavior before you
then offer
incentives to do it more long term it's
a tough one isn't it because if you help
people you remove the incentive to
change but unless you help people i
think the squeeze on living standards
we've calculated it will be
6.2 percent over the two years this year
and next year
that is unprecedented in peacetime and i
don't think that any government could
get away without doing something about
it
and inflation predicted it could go up
to 8.7
next quarter
how high do you think it could go well
the 8.7 is is my prediction actually and
that other people are now picking up um
i think it's not just the fact that
inflation is going to have a high peak
um because we were actually expecting
the price for inflation to hit seven
percent even before the war started
the biggest change since the war started
is it now looks as if it's going to stay
at that peak level um
for at least a year and that's a huge
change previously what we were expecting
was it would hit the peak and come right
right back down again now it looks as if
it's going to stay up there and that's
part of the squeeze on living standards
so even if the war in ukraine were to
end tomorrow
it wouldn't have a an immediate impact
on on the cost of living for most people
in the uk
i think it would start to affect um
petrol prices which are probably the
most sensitive to the commodity markets
but for example there are fields that
haven't been planted so the idea the
price of wheat will fall immediately
seems a bit unlikely sunflower oil it's
up 50 percent of the shops at the moment
i don't see that coming back very
quickly so there are quite a lot of
things that are good where prices are
going to stay up for the better part of
this year or at least until we move into
the next season and think the fields can
be replanted again
and of course we're looking at this from
a purely uk perspective but the impact
as we've been discussing this morning
across the rest of the world of these
things like shortages and sunflower oil
and wheat are are more dramatic for
other economies aren't they well they're
more dramatic for those other economies
that depend more on the price of food
we're sort of lucky in this country that
being a relatively wealthy country we
spend just a bit more than 10 percent on
food but if you go to other places like
china or russia itself
30 of the cost of living is food and
they obviously get hit that much more
really interested to talk to you douglas
smith williams in advance of tomorrow's
spring statement uh from the center for
economics and business research thank
you thank you very much
and we'll be bringing you live coverage
of the chancellor's spring statement
tomorrow from 11 o'clock join me from
westminster where we will be anchoring
our coverage uh through our prime
minister's questions the spring
statement and getting uh some
predictions beforehand and some
reactions afterwards as well
now as the war in ukraine continues
hundreds of volunteers are traveling
from britain to help people fleeing the
country escape the fighting our special
correspondent alex crawford has been
talking to leon cribb who was an
ambulance technician in chichester but
decided to head to ukraine two weeks ago
what made you decide to come here it's a
really good question
lots of different answers i think the
most important is i was sat home one
evening and looking at the news and i
thought to myself
how could i not do something about this
how can i not go out there and help
especially seeing the war crimes being
committed on civilian populations i just
thought that i can't can't sit by and
let this happen
it reminded me of stories that my
grandmother and grandfather taught me
about the first world war a second world
war even in britain you know
and i thought to myself
in this century
we're experiencing stuff like this still
and by a first world country like russia
that's just
it's criminal
but a lot of people i think feel very
deeply about it but they've taken up
volunteering or delivering aid or
helping and raise money i mean coming
and putting yourself on the front line
is a whole different ball game isn't it
for sure i think if you can do that then
it's valuable to do that because there
aren't many people
i think that would want to do that and
of course most people my age have a wife
and kids to worry about so
being in that position i i don't have to
worry about what my wife is thinking of
me or my children are thinking of me so
i can just
do what i need to do and get hands on
right on the front line and
try and help it the best way i can and
what sort of action have you seen so far
probably the worst thing i saw were a
stabilization point which used to be a
children's hospital um
quite far north in fact it's probably
quite close to where we are now
probably further west but um
we had a russian artillery shell go off
about 100 meters from the hospital
building blew out all the windows
that was quite a stark realization of
how little of a down the russians give
about ukrainians
did you feel like you came close to
getting hurt or injured yourself no
no i
it's difficult to explain but
i mean with artillery you're never going
to know until after you've been hit so
i always i always thought when i was a
kid if if someone you know if i ended up
in a war zone i'd seen it on the tv i
always thought that wow how do people
put up with that knowing that they might
get blown up any any second that when
you're actually there and it's peace and
quiet like this you just forget all
about it there's no point worrying about
what could be
there's a lot of talk about potential
war crimes being committed what have you
seen on the ground that either backs
that up or not i've seen
medics wounded by russian
rifle rounds
i've
heard countless tales i've personally
never seen medics shot at myself in the
short time i've been here but i've heard
countless stories from 2014 of medics
being shot at
especially by russian sharpshooters
who seem to be trained to shoot medics
first
i'm not sure about the average russian
soldier but from what i've heard they
also will pick on medics
what have you seen this time that might
show that they're targeting civilians or
ambulance workers or
anyone i've seen he's a non-competent
i've seen bullet holes stricken all
across our ambulances at the hq
um of russian caliber
and
you know the hospitals that we go to
that are just shattered windows and
sandbags all up it's like
nothing i've ever seen before it's
incredible
and what's the reaction been from
the fellow ukrainian fighters that
you're alongside
to you yeah
they're they're really glad to have us
here in any way possible and
never underestimate the value of just
being there and having our flag on your
arm because that means the world to them
because they know that we're sending
them weapons and we're sending them
vehicles
trying to help out passively as much as
we can but just being there
in person
it keeps their mind
at ease knowing that we're
that the whole world stands with them
now you may remember a touching moment
in the early days of the russian
invasion of ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
food
seven-year-old emilia anisovich
who captured many hearts when she sang
let it go from the movie frozen in
ukrainian in her bomb shelter
well look at her now
[Music]
she performed the national anthem at a
charity concert in lots in poland she
escaped ukraine three weeks ago with her
grandmother and siblings but her mum and
dad have stayed behind in kiev
[Music]
[Applause]
prince william has expressed his
solidarity with people in ukraine he was
speaking on a visit to belize during his
tour of the caribbean
well this report from sky's role
correspondent ryan mills does contain
flash
photography the last royal to come to
the ruins at cahill pech was the queen
in her platinum jubilee year her
grandson and granddaughter-in-law were
the ones delivering her warm wishes
long live the queen que viva la reina
william used the moment to recall his
grandmother's words of praise for belize
in 1994 to then condemn the horrors
taking place in ukraine
she said
i am proud to associate myself with your
determination
that social justice and personal freedom
should flourish under the rule of law
it is always dangerous however to be
complacent and to assume that democratic
values will look after themselves
vigilance in protecting them
is needed
sadly
elsewhere in the world
that vigilance is being tested today in
ukraine
belize has joined many others in
condemning the invasion
and standing out for the principles of
international law
peace and security
today we think of those struggling in
ukraine
and we stand with them in solidarity
it was a reminder these tours aren't all
about sightseeing after mourning among
the mayan ruins at caracal
the couple standing on the sky palace
still the largest man-made structure in
belize was the picture until they were
joined by some of us
these pictures are priceless for the
people of belize a tour brings immense
global attention and a stage the royal
couple know they can also personally use
to deliver the messages that matters so
much to them
rhiannon mills sky news in belize
this is sky news today coming up a
review of the unsolved murder of
danielle morgan concludes the mets
approach to tackling corruption is not
fit for purpose we're going to talk to
the report's author surely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
bubbles have been pulled up
out and have been used as missiles of
hell
at these
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
we have now left italy and entered
france nobody's asked to check our
identity
[Music]
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney
why committing you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie an enormous economic feeling
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
it's uh devastating actually
[Music]
a lot of action going on i'm alex
crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
this is what makes the job so fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a new report has concluded that the
metropolitan police's process for
tackling corruption is not fit for
purpose but says it would not describe
the force as institutionally corrupt it
follows the murder of daniel morgan the
private investigator whose death 35
years ago remains unsolved
while the metropolitan police have
released a statement in response to the
report it says there is clearly much
more work to do when it comes to
tackling corruption in its widest sense
we are absolutely committed to this we
are deeply concerned at the criticisms
in the report on our approach to
countering corruption and are urgently
reviewing our systems and processes
the police inspectorate said it would
not describe the met as institutionally
corrupt and there was no evidence of
deliberate or coordinated attempts to
frustrate the daniel morgan independent
panel we welcome this
well let's talk to the report author
matt parr and good to talk to you today
the independent report last summer did
conclude that the met was
institutionally racist and
that the met had put up a huge number of
barriers to their report
why did you not find it to be
institutionally corrupt
well good afternoon um we found an awful
lot wrong with it let's be clear and
there's uh huge areas of agreement
between us and the panel
and as you said in neural contraction
the
uh the met's got an awful lot to do to
get its anti-corruption practices to
where they should be i think where the
slight difference was and of bearing in
mind we had different remits as we
simply didn't see evidence that the
mistakes amit had made
were dishonest or were sort of
coordinated uh in a campaign to
frustrate the the panels uh work um we
saw lots of things that went wrong and
there are lots of things we criticized
and met for but i think without that
element of deliberate dishonesty uh it's
not a phrase that we'd use to call them
institutionally corrupt
that doesn't mean there isn't an awful
lot wrong and it's a very critical
report
well indeed and let's look at some of
those those things that are wrong
the mets employing criminals employing
people who've committed crimes why
does the police force do this
well i think every case should be judged
on its merits there might be occasions
where
someone who's had some sort of
transgression a few years beforehand
relatively minor should be allowed to
become a police officer
we do think that the mets tolerance for
things like that and their risk appetite
as they called it
is too high but where we're more
concerned is if you are going to take
somebody like that in and there might be
reasons to do so
it's a higher risk and therefore you
ought to monitor it carefully and they
ought to supervise it more carefully and
there's not enough evidence of that
going on
and in fact all sorts of degrees of
supervision of people who have
associations with criminals or have got
a checkered past
and nowhere near they ought to be
i mean why is this happening that
these people are not then being
monitored once they're into the force
i mean like you i
sort of look at it and wonder how on
earth
after 35 years of criticism over
daniel morgan the way they handled the
initial investigation the subsequent
investigations the failures in court
in which police corruption was a very
major factor uh we find it uh
bewildering
that no one seems to have said this is
something that we can't put up with
we've got to get it right
we've got to be absolutely sure over
this now
doing all the things that we've
recommended and recommended 20
areas for improvement
doing all those things doesn't guarantee
that you never get any corruption of
force but i think it's the minimum that
the public would expect is that the met
should be doing all it can to minimize
that and at the moment it just isn't so
you know essentially it almost seems
that what you're finding is that there
isn't sort of an institutional
conspiracy to be corrupt
but but there is corruption just by by
the fault of almost indifference
uh in is a word we use in the report
it's what it looks like to us uh i'm
sure the met will say differently but uh
there were low standards in the way they
looked after property which again was a
feature with exhibits of the daniel
morgan case there were poor standards in
the way they supervise people some of
their policies are not in accordance
with what the national guidance says
and there were just you know
people not doing the right things to
minimize the risk of corruption almost
across the board now there were some
pockets of real excellence so one of the
things we congratulate the met for is
that they had a big
vetting backlog they had 16 000 people
unvetted uh three or four years ago and
they've pretty much eradicated that and
the real high profile uh serious cases
they investigate those really well
but it's all the other things that they
ought to do
to to make sure the wrong people don't
join the met and if they do to make sure
that they're found out and they can't
get away with corrupt behavior it's all
those little things that they ought to
be doing uh that that on their own don't
look as important but in some uh they
present a picture for us of a force that
doesn't really take it as seriously as
it should especially after what's gone
wrong in in the daniel morgan case what
do you think it says about an
organization that they're not keeping
track of of warrant cards and how has
access codes for security things etched
on doors
yeah i mean it says something about the
culture of the organization doesn't it i
mean we've we've all seen these dreadful
uh cases where misogyny sexism racism
has
has blackened the met's reputation uh
but i think you know as an organization
you look at culture wider than that it's
it's how people behave when no one's
looking it's surely the first person to
see that there's this security breach
should pick it up and correct it uh
surely it's everybody should know that
if there's somebody who's got a uh a
declarable association with somebody who
has to be related to someone who's an
active criminal
that should be supervised and people
should be aware and they're just not so
i think it speaks of an organization
that hasn't really got a grip
on this particularly important part
of police culture and practice
very interesting to talk to you thanks
very much for joining us there matt parr
h inspector of constabulary's carryouts
report into the daniel morgan case
now police in merseyside have named a
toddler who died after being attacked by
a dog as 17 month old bella ray burch
this guy's becky cottrell has the latest
bella ray burch was attacked in her home
here yesterday she was taken to hospital
in an ambulance but sadly died from her
injuries and we've been speaking to
neighbours who spoke of how
understandably hysterical her mother was
in the aftermath of that we've also
just seen a man outside the house who
said he is belarey's granddad and he was
visibly emotional and talking about how
he is now grieving we got a few more
details from the police this morning
they made a statement outside the house
and this is superintendent steve brazell
the community of black brook and the
whole of merseyside has woken up today
to the most tragic news
officers were called to attend a house
here on bidston avenue at around 3 50
p.m yesterday
at this stage we understand that the
family dog they had bought just a week
earlier has attacked belaret inside the
family home
bella ray was taken by ambulance to
hospital by paramedics but despite the
best efforts of police officers
at scene the paramedics and doctors
sadly bella ray died as a result of her
injuries yesterday afternoon
it has left a family and a community
grieving and in complete shock
during the incident the dog was handed
over to police at the address and has
been humanely destroyed
detailed investigations are continuing
into this tragic event and those
investigations will involve forensic
tests on the dog they will want to
establish if he was a legal breed under
the dangerous dog act neighbors that
we've spoken to have said that the dog
appeared to be a staffordshire bull
terrier or a pit bull
but those tests will confirm that one
neighbor said the dog had seemed
friendly but as you heard from the
superintendent there it was a new dog
only a week old
one of the most
moving
interviews with a neighbor that we spoke
to on the estate was a woman named
jordan she is due to go to university to
train to be a paramedic and she actually
helped out before the paramedics arrived
she performed at cpr on belare for 30
seconds and this is what she told us
i just said scream we pulled up from
school heard screaming and just run over
and
try to help that's
that's it just
it's normal because i don't know i just
don't know how to feel
she like others that we spoke to here
are visibly traumatized this is a
devastating incident it's unimaginable
what the family are going through but
also here in the community a deep sense
of sadness
becky cottrell there
let's go look now at the weather
well the next few days are going to be
mostly fine with long clear spells
bringing warm days and chilly nights
it'll be warmer than yesterday for most
of us this afternoon with a high of 20
celsius 68 fahrenheit in the southeast
of england and also in northwest wales
an onshore breeze will keep it cooler
near some coasts mainly in the northeast
and the southwest it'll be largely dry
with good sunny spells but a few heavy
showers are possible the midlands and
ireland look most at risk
oh the odd shower can't be ruled out
over northern england and southern
scotland the showers will soon fade to
leave a dry and clear night with apache
frost developing in the countryside
you're watching sky news coming up calls
from the ukrainian president for direct
talks with russia's vladimir putin we'll
have the latest on the conflict next
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello it's two o'clock you're watching
the sarah j me show coming up today
ukraine's president warns his country is
clinging on to survival as russia's
bombardment of mariopol continues there
are russian troops who are killing and
raping people and kidnapping children
torturing people and looting
a 17 month old girl killed by a dog at
her home on merseyside is named as bella
ray burch
a damning report says the metropolitan
police haven't learned the lessons of
the unsolved murder of daniel morgan
which led to the force being accused of
institutional corruption
no sign of survivors as search teams
comb the site of a plane crash in china
and protest plan in jamaica over royal
links to the slave trade as the duke and
duchess of cambridge prepare to touch
down
[Music]
hello good afternoon ukraine's president
today says his country is clinging on to
survival as the russian military
continues to bombard ukraine vladimir
zelinski addressed the italian
parliament this morning warning that
ukraine represents the gates to europe
for russia the southern city of mariopol
continues to take the brunt of russia's
attacks after ukrainian forces refused
to surrender
well residents in the capital kiev have
been ordered to stay at home or in
shelters with a 35-hour curfew in place
until 7am local time tomorrow
more than 3.5 million have now fled the
country with 6.5 million people
displaced within ukraine
u.s president joe biden who is to travel
to brussels has warned american
companies they are likely to be targeted
by russian cyber attacks
and ukraine's president has said that
russia
has been looting and kidnapping children
charlotte lomas has this report
one after another the bombs fall
this time the target is an industrial
center in maripo
factories that once provided jobs
destroyed in an instant
maripola has been under constant fire
for weeks
homes across the city reduced to ruin
officials say around 90 percent of
buildings have been damaged here
the incessant fighting has forced these
ukrainian families to flee
but with nowhere to go they line their
cars along one of the